And now we have seen RAID 0, 1, 2, there
is a 3 but we didn't see it, 4, and 5.
Is there such a thing as RAID 6?
Yes, there is.
It's similar to RAID 5 except
that each group of blocks,
instead of getting one parity block,
gets two.
Let's call them parity quoted blocks.
They have different types of parity.
And as a results, RAID 6 can work when
there are two failed stripes per group.
Note that we cannot do this
with two parity blocks.
One of the blocks that we keep extra,
one of the known data blocks is going
to be the real parity block, and
that's what fixes one error.
The second of the two blocks is
a different type of check-blocks, and
when only one disk has failed,
we use the parity to recover.
But when two disks have failed,
we can still solve some equations,
where the data and
the two types of check-blocks figure, so
that we can still recover
the content of the two failed disks.
So let's compare RAID 5 and RAID 6.
RAID 6 has twice the overhead of RAID 5,
so we pay twice as much for
this increased reliability.
There is more write overhead because
really now when we update a data block
we need to read and write the data
block and both of the check-blocks,
the parity and the second one
are also read and written.
So there are now six accesses per write
versus four per write
that we had with RAID 5.
So the only reason for having RAID 6,
if there is a good chance
of when a disk fails,
another one failing before we manage
to replace the failed first drive.
So note that in any of the RAID
configurations, once your disk fails,
you don't keep going and
ignore the failed drive.
You keep going, but
you order a replacement or
get a replacement and install it so that
the RAID array can re-establish itself.
After that, you can lose another disk.
So really RAID 6,
with its ability to lose two disks,
only helps if when a disk fails,
there is a good
chance of another failing before
the first one is replaced.
The faster we replace the first drive,
the less chance there is that another
disk fails during that period of time.
Remember that the probability of a disk
failing during an hour is extremely low,
so even if we spent something like three
days replacing a disk, the probability
of a disk failing in that specific time,
while we are vulnerable,
is very, very low, and then it
seems that RAID 6 is an overkill.